fast moving lava from Hawaii's Kilauea
Volcano force new emergency evacuations
overnight the most active Fisher is
shooting molten rock hundreds of feet
into the air lava has now destroyed 112
structures including 71 homes Carter
Evans is in Pahoa Hawaii where an
important roadway was just blocked
Carter good morning to you good morning
you can see this tremendous fountain
behind me right now it's blasting lava
up to 200 feet into the air this is the
most active fissure right now it's
producing massive lava flows that have
cut off major highways shut down a power
plant and destroyed dozens of homes the
2,000 degree molten rock exploding from
the ground is creating rivers of lava
continue to devastate this community and
literally change the landscape one of
the first things you notice when you're
standing next to a lava fountain this
big is the intense heat I can feel it
radiating on my back it's probably more
than 100 degrees here but much of this
lava is already cool enough to walk on
the lava forced the closure of highway
130 to a major artery for people who
live here it also leads to the main
access road for the area's geothermal
power plant meanwhile health authorities
are warning of a new hazard it's called
Kelly's hair a glass it's like glass
it's fragile it's light weight as
Marianne Ferrell got ready to leave her
home in Leilani Estates for perhaps the
last time she showed us the rocks with
glass fibers that can irritate the skin
and eyes and lungs if inhaled this stuff
is is all over it's all around your
house all over my catchment it's raining
down what do you think of when you see
this
it's over Chris burmeister says he's
seen his Leilani estates neighborhood go
from a lush jungle to a moonscape can
you try and explain that the force that
we're looking at here there's nothing
like it
it's definitely Mother Nature recreating
so we're at it for mercy because there
are still so many active fishers right
now there's really no word on when any
roads might reopen if at all this
eruption has been going on for almost a
month right now and scientists aren't
offering any predictions for when it
might end Nora all right Carter Evans in
Hawaii thank you